Speaker 1: All right, so this you have to
see as if things couldn't get any worse for
Rudy Giuliani, he has now been completely
exposed by some newly released audio recordings
in which he just straight up calls Ukraine
and says, hey, here's what we need you to
say about investigating Joe Biden.
And this goes back, of course, to Donald Trump,
supposedly perfect phone call with Ukraine
and the entire impeachment fiasco.
Rudy's house has been searched.
Rudy's office has been search.
Rudy farted multiple times during that bogus,
bogus voter fraud hearing in Michigan or who
knows where that one was.
Rudy represented the most pathetic failure
of a president in the modern political era
and now caught on audio recordings.
It just won't stop.
This is new content, and Rudy is potentially
in some really serious trouble here.
So let's listen to the first clip.
There's something notable here.
There's an important detail, which is actually
a theme of these clips, which we suspected
before.
So see if you can spot it on this first time
through
Speaker 2: what we need, what we need for
the president in the state to put an honest
prosecutor in charge.
He's going to investigate and dig up the evidence
that presently exists.
And is there any other evidence about involvement
of the 2016 election?
And then the final thing has to be run out?
I don't know if it's true or not.
I mean, I see I see him bragging about it
on television.
And he is a lawyer to me as a lawyer, it sounds
like a bribe.
Speaker 1: Did you notice that Rudy keeps
saying we need him to say we are investigating
Biden.
This is not Rudy wanting justice done.
He doesn't actually say we need the investigation
to be done.
He insists that they need the investigation
announced.
And we had a sense that this was the case
from what we knew before.
Remember our understanding before we didn't
have recordings, but our understanding before
was they were asking for the announcement
of an investigation.
They didn't really care about the investigation
itself because they wanted the propaganda
value to say, look, Ukraine has just announced
an investigation.
Whether it took place or not, it didn't even
really matter.
It wasn't about proving Joe Biden did anything
or Hunter Biden did anything.
It was about claiming they are doing an investigation
period.
Joe Biden is under investigation is what they
wanted from a propaganda perspective.
And there's more of that phraseology in this
next segment.
Let's check it out and listen to the exact
same thing.
Speaker 2: If you could make some statement
at the right time, but in support of law enforcement
system and that these investigations go wherever
they have to go, it's going to be run by honest
people that we be really wrong.
Speaker 1: So there it is again.
If he could make some statements at the right
time, justice has no right time, Rudy.
Come on.
But Rudy doesn't care about justice and Rudy
doesn't care about finding out what happened.
That's not what this was about.
This was Rudy and Trump deciding.
We want an announcement that there's an investigation
into Joe Biden at a time that is politically
suitable, meaning suitable for Trump in trying
to get himself reelected against who he imagined
would be his opponent, Joe Biden.
Let's listen to the last bit here and here.
You actually get the offer of the quid pro
quo.
It's it's stunning that it's all on tape.
Guys, we have the recordings now.
Here is the quid pro quo offer.
Speaker 2: All right.
I think it would make it possible for me to
come and make it possible, I think for me
to talk to the president to see what I can
do about making sure that whatever misunderstandings
are put aside and maybe even kind of think
that this is this could be a solution for
having a much a much better relationship where
we really understand each other.
Speaker 1: So there's the closing of the circle
on the quid pro quo.
If you announce these investigations into
Joe Biden, not even if you do them, if you
announce the investigations into Joe Biden,
then I can talk to Trump and we can resolve
all of those misunderstandings.
This is gangster code.
This is mafia code.
Right?
This is you never fully say it, but you say,
you know our problem.
I think if you were able to cut me in as a
partner on this business, which means give
me some money so I don't rip your, you know,
whatever off, if you could make me a partner
in this in this enterprise, I think I'd be
able to go and talk to, you know, who.
And we could really come to an understanding
about what.
Whoa, what?
What are you talking about that is the language
that Rudy is using here, we could resolve
the misunderstanding by me talking to Trump.
I'll talk to Trump and it's all going to be
resolved.
Meaning I will get the messages you want over
to Trump and we can deal with sanctions.
We can get you the military aid, whatever
you want.
Our problems, we're going to be able to solve
them.
If these investigations are announced into
Joe Biden, it's almost identical to.
I need you to do us a favor, though.
I need you to it from the perfect phone call,
They were working for that favor among multiple
angles.
And we now have the latest bit of it, which
is Rudy on tape asking for it.
When does it become treason?
For the personal lawyer to the president of
the United States, then sitting president
to offer favors to other countries in exchange
for favorable public announcements to help
that sitting president in his ongoing reelection
campaign, at some point, don't we have to
start using that term?
Stunning and disgusting stuff doesn't look
good for Rudy